[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we are asking the question
what are we most looking forward to in
this the year that is 2019 2000 in the
nineteen don't say 2019 2019 left that
behind 21 nine it's you know it's so
fresh I'm so so glad to be here
experiencing 2019 to be in the middle of
it
hmm I don't even remember 2018 it is
such a distant memory hmm
yeah that I I can't even access I can't
even
well I've imagined I remember 2018 and
some thinking about 2019 I remember some
things about it like capping it off with
an incredible holiday season yep
spend it here in Los Angeles yeah first
time ever
didn't have any there was no
interpersonal conflict between me and my
family for the first time me neither
yeah there's no arguments at all hey it
seemed grateful for everything that they
got for Christmas I'll tell my my
president I'll tell you the presidents
I'm gonna get in in a little bit and
they were perfect like things I didn't
know that I wanted I got and they
weren't only for my benefit with a bit
of benefit of society well it's right
this is probably a good time to tell you
in the New Year's Eve party yeah a great
time to tell you that it's hard he still
2018 when we're recording this not yet
experienced any of the holiday
festivities but we're basically just
trying to make it seem like they went
great yeah so in the next year biscuit
I predict that we will record it in the
new year and that we will talk about and
give each other and you an update on how
our 2018 wound down in terms of the
holidays in the new years and I'm I'm
planning to go to Sedona I'm gonna check
out some Sedona Sedona you don't say
so don't assay tried to say yeah
the time this comes it out I will be
back from that and then so the next
recording now I'll tell you all about it
and my my gifts that I didn't know would
be so amazing and New Year's Eve and all
that jazz so I'm going to make oh but
you're going on a romantic excursion I
am the children are being left alone at
home to fend for themselves you know ten
and fourteen I feel like that's adequate
we back in the 1800s are you serious
yeah back in the eighteen hundred's you
could just you could leave at in you you
can leave a four-year-old alone for
months and they fended for themselves
and I like learn how to hunt I mean we
we gave we gave Locke access to the car
he looks old enough to drive and the
grocery store is not too far from the
house he's gonna eat it he's got a
credit card he's gonna keep him having
it I did believe you for a little bit
you thought was gonna leave my kids home
alone you were very convincing really I
mean I thought that we ran out we like
expended all of our lies in the previous
bit and I thought you were done we got
lies for days well I should know the
kids will be being taken care of by a
responsible adult and but they will not
be with me yeah that right well my
compromise my kids are gonna be with me
but I'm gonna we're not doing the RV
thing which I don't know if I'll regret
that I'll let you know so anyway we're
gonna give you an update on everything
that happened but for now we are
absolutely in the 2019 mindset we've got
some things that we've pulled together
that we know we're happening in the
coming year that boy when I start going
through this list I get I get excited
you know I like I like having little
some of those like little silly or
frivolous things that I can just go
ahead and put on my calendar
we're just like some asterisks it's like
you know just a little pop to your life
just a little something to look forward
to it could be a movie it could be an
album it could be something personal or
something professional we'll get in all
that yeah yeah we will we will get
somewhat personal
mm-hmm but a lot of these things are
things that you you're gonna have an
opportunity to enjoy yourself if you
have access to an internet connection
and you're not living under a rock
you'll be able to enjoy these things as
well do you want to go ahead and talk
about some of them yeah let's right now
yeah I think an easy category to start
with is movies I have this some let's
see what is this I have an app called
Flixter I got that app too and now we're
powered by Rotten Tomatoes not a sponsor
but yeah it's got it you know it gives
it gives all the ratings in there but it
also tells you when new movies are
coming out and you can scroll sometimes
you can scroll like months and months
and months in advance and avoid it I
find a gem in there well first of all
before we get into the specific movies I
know a lot of people have you know
there's a there's a not insignificant
percentage of people who when you talk
about when you start talking about
movies and what you're gonna see and it
has been reviewed and you're like I
didn't get great reviews it's only got a
so-and-so on Rotten Tomatoes yeah and
then they're like I don't really I don't
really go by that you know you're saying
I go by it but there's not an incident
not a small percentage of people who
just ignore what Rotten Tomatoes says as
if Rotten Tomatoes is one thing Rotten
Tomatoes is by definition an aggregate
score of both critics and in separately
fans and certain so submitting yourself
to it drastically increases your chances
of seeing a good movie Feldman you're
upset about this because you like to
think of yourself as like an opinionated
art my brothers up who doesn't want to
it's it's a betting game that you'll win
but what will happen is yeah you're an
individual you know I make you like that
getting you know why you can play that
game because you don't have children man
if you have children you can't risk that
you also don't have taste
you you can't really joke a big part of
your job is taste
oh good laning is because the people who
have told me they don't go by Rotten
Tomatoes talk to me as if rotten
tomatoes is just a guy named Rotten
Tomatoes you know yeah if if like a Oh
Scott was the only person shout out to a
film critic that I can think of it might
not even be right if he was the only one
that was on there that I'm not gonna go
buy one critics recommendations but it's
an aggregate and it's not like I mean
even though I do also do the same thing
with restaurants and Yelp and then
people are like but yeah people can beat
the system on Yelp yes they can and it
happens occasionally but as a general
rule if there's a if there's a large
number of reviews it's a pretty accurate
predictor of what kind of experience
you're gonna have at a restaurant
there's a reason that these apps exist
are you this is not an app this is not
an ad for an app Flixster or Rotten
Tomatoes is just you know I think we're
of the same school of thought here that
I'm not gonna waste my time if it's not
certified fresh' so I mean I didn't
provoke the rant I don't know who you've
been talking to the Feldman was just
looking the other way we interpret that
as meaning a rant fired at him um
rant cannon on Star Wars Episode X he's
coming out gay you know that that'll be
I believe that's towards the end of the
year here's the thing I I don't know
because I try to know so little because
I'm I want to experience it with with
know with without being influenced by
anything so episode nine but do you like
to know at what point in the story it
comes well I've seen the other ones so
no I mean I don't want all I want to
know is what I know from seeing the
other ones which yeah I'll watch them
again what's the kylo and race situation
what are they up to
they making babies yet I hope they're
not related and making babies uh I'll
definitely see it
well Darth Vader come back as a ghost
I'm not you know I'm just
I enjoy the I enjoy the films
I you know I can't might had a word of
taking like my whole family back in
North Carolina when I was at home for
Christmas you know about when they were
coming out every Christmas you couldn't
get away from him yeah I would take
everybody to the to the to the movie but
I don't know I just can't say I didn't I
didn't become excited about it I am I'll
I I really like the last one I'm not I'm
not too picky
I'm just I'm just happy when the when
it's done well so I'm not gonna mention
that solo movie oh so your take your
extracting solo out of this you saying
it's like a blip on the radar and your
don't even hear it I'll tell you what I
am excited about is but I'm not watching
any my final point is that I'm not
watching or listen no trailers if I'm
watching another movie and the trailer
for Star Wars comes on I am literally
going to close up every orifice like I'm
gonna I'm gonna go into like a tornado
drill type situation I just I like I
it's just that's what keeps it special
for me and my family they'll probably
have to see him and they'll get all
excited and I like so they don't we
still get very excited don't abide by
the same principle know they don't know
sake can't resist they can't resist they
get mad at me cuz they want to tell me
about it and I get mad cuz I'm like I
better buy the movie I'm most excited
about but I'm also a little bit
apprehensive about I'm anxious about it
is Jordan peels movie us which is his
you could call it a follow up to get out
it's you shouldn't but here's the thing
it it has nothing to do well he's making
it right well it has what it has to do
with it it is another horror movie that
plays into is a commentary on racial
issues oh it is yeah and so so first of
all that's what make it out so great
right I mean everything about get out
made get out great a the fact that it
was completely unexpected it's like what
is this guy
from a comedic duo suddenly doing making
a movie it would be like one of us
making a movie that was good that's not
gonna happen
and all of a sudden yeah and you can't
recreate that part of it that unexpected
huge success 30 million dollar opening
weekend 100 million plus dollars gross
is like that the stant he set such a
high bar that that's a difficult thing
but it also means he can write his own
check at this point and but anyway the
thing that made it great was if you
haven't seen it please even if you're a
person is like I don't like horror
movies I don't like them uh these I
don't like I don't understand
no spicy well anyone would want to be
like purposely like around that negative
energy like why would you submit
yourself to something that kind of thing
because it just makes me feel triggered
and I don't want to watch it especially
if it's highly rated on rotten tomato
that guy and hunt means nothing to me if
Rotten Tomatoes said that it was good
didn't my experience is that he's wrong
and it's bad I'm not going to see it
sorry you know 2019 is the new Rhett
even meaner than 2018 not even actually
that scare just ramping up for it yeah
go see it it's not you're not gonna get
hurt
it's a movie who tinkled in your it's
not even smellivision yes cereal it's
not even one of those rides at
Disneyland where all of a sudden you get
sprinkled with water that doesn't happen
it's just you're in a seat it's a screen
it's just images now well did I hurt you
I wonder if the Twilight Zone movie
which I don't know if he's directing
he's producing he's he was in he was
producing a number of movies that I
think are coming out this year as well
so he's like he's got this backlog they
were talking there was one maybe it was
us then it was the Twilight Zone so I
don't know which one comes up well but
so I'm sorry I keep getting sidetracked
but it was so unexpected it was so good
it was so legitimately scary suspenseful
it was well
did all the performances were great it
can't us can't be as good because the
surprise elements gone it was funny and
I hope it is uh it what have to this
very timely brilliant commentary on a on
racial issues that it was a commentary
on racism in a way in a like this fresh
unexpected way they actually sort of
highlighted the racism of white people
who don't realize that the racist right
it was you know baby you it was just
everyone seen the movie no but what I'm
saying is is that let me I'm just
pointing out the fact with it why it was
so brilliant because it wasn't the it
was just so unexpected and so great in
so many ways and then he said that he
has always wanted to for a very long
period of time had in his mind a way to
explore those kinds of social issues
through horror and that he had a bunch
of ideas lined up and us was the next
one that he had lined up let me just
give you a few details because I want
you to get excited about this oh I'm
excited I'm if I'm afraid I'm actually
trying to lower the bar and say success
is a 75% of get out
he's coming out March 2019
it's centers around two couples one
black and one white the black couple is
played by Winston Duke from he played in
Baku and black panther in Lupita Nyong'o
is the the woman in that couple and then
the white couple is Elisabeth Moss is so
white and speaking of why you don't know
Tim Heidecker Tim Heidecker he's white -
Tim Heidecker of Tim and Eric yeah Lisa
plays the boyfriend her husband I don't
know that I'd forgotten this and that's
amazing I mean he took a dramatic turn
in a movie that I didn't see that I read
about I can't remember what it's called
but I'm stood in a very tight alley with
Tim Heidecker one time for the mythical
show remember that tight alley yeah that
was um they really slathered on the
awkward
yeah in it I could barely take it but I
I didn't I didn't I didn't crumble the
comedy was the name of Tim's movie
well it was ironically titled and not
only that Duke Nicholson who's Jack
Nicholson's 22 year old grandson is
making his acting debut in this movie
what yeah Jack Nicholson's grandson
Nicholson is a great name you can't get
excited about this sounds like an
inventor like a guy like a Ron Popeil
kind of guy like and now another
vegetable cutting device from the mind
of Duke Nicholson he's also an actor
yeah well anyway I am super excited
about it I do realize that I and I do
agree with you that the chances that it
can't it just can't be if it was if it
was as good as get out it the argument
is this the argument for those of you
who care about this I've heard this our
Michael Rapaport make this argument
about why LeBron can never be as good as
Jordan okay and that is because Michael
Jordan changed the game so significantly
that no one else unless they're like
from a different planet can change the
game in the way that Jordan did so he
literally changed everything about the
game now that all of a sudden people had
their own shoe and people had their own
brand and he played completely
differently like he introduced things
that seemed otherworldly to the game
that LeBron can only add on to so in a
one-on-one match sure maybe LeBron would
be Jordan who we can't really we don't
know but he can't like so what I think
we do know but this the stage it was set
for Jordan to come and make for Jordan
Thompson told me Oh another Jordan even
mean to say that Jordan Peele to make
this movie in a way that he can't
replicate the like you said the
unexpected success so now it's just like
is it gonna be as good so it actually
has it stands a great chance to be a
better movie but even it has to be twice
as good which is impossible right
in order to because I think about the M
night Shyamalan Sixth Sense
being followed up by unbreakable which I
really like unbreakable you know it was
kind of a shame because I really liked
it for it to come out after six cents
which I haven't seen well yeah your what
you're joking right hello huh
you haven't seen six cents you're joking
that's a joke I know I know you haven't
seen a lot of movies but you've seen six
cents I did i missed that one you missed
that one I it was kind of a Blair Witch
kind of situation no it wasn't yeah what
what do you mean by that I don't know
why I didn't see it I saw unbreakable
though I tried to catch out I see in the
next one and I really liked it
because you know I really liked it
because I hadn't seen six cents but six
cents didn't find that weird 80s time
well you were you were in a weird
situation and I didn't aim what was
happening I was the person you were
making fun of it's like I just doesn't
seem like a type this seems like a
spooky movie I don't like those kind of
movies but how did I see it what year
did six cents come out like 98 I didn't
anyway I think the advice is if you
haven't seen get out don't see it before
see us watch us first and love it and
then go back and watch get out second
that's what you need to do that's it
all right we're gonna get I I got
another movie that I'm super super
excited about is happening and then
we'll move on to some other stuff but
first we want to let you know if you
didn't already see it that there's a mug
on the table that says ear biscuits on
it this is the new ear biscuits mug it's
no longer a jar now it's a mug it has a
handle for those of you who complain
about not having something to hold on to
other than your loved one now and even
if you if you especially if you don't
have a loved one this 2019 to hold on to
well you can hold on to our mug it feels
it's not as soft as a person not as warm
as a body but holds well actually holds
less water and you can get out but it's
cheaper is cheaper it's cheaper than
like a subscription to a dating service
and it's potentially find a mate you can
get a set of three
there's this there's the L type mug and
the brand new good mythical morning
official mug they work all three
together they play very well together
for the first time you can pour water or
any liquid from one mug to the next and
then back it's a little bit like a magic
trick go to mythical dot store support
internat Ament and rep the stuff that
you love especially if it's us rip your
boys I thought that was your line rep
you boys well let me tell you about this
um first of all I'm not gonna I'm just
gonna say this very quickly that at the
end of July the new Tarantino film Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood comes out you
just can't ignore this movie because
it's got Brad Pitt Leonardo DiCaprio
Margo Roby Margot Robbie Al Pacino the
late Burt Reynolds and how they do that
CGI no they shot the film before he died
and drumroll please Duke Nicholson Luke
Perry Luke Perry sy burns well we saw
him in Mel's Diner when we came to
Hollywood and thought we were we were
meeting with the potential manager this
is like this is what Hollywood manager
leave me at meet me at the Mel's Diner
we go out can be a manager and we go in
there we set out he's like hey I can be
a manager you guys he's got some talent
you got some talent wise and we look it
over his shoulder he did not become our
manager so I'm not making fun of we
don't have a manager I looked over the
shoulder and there's Luke Perry were
like dang we're at the wrong table
yeah Luke Perry to be our manager I am
excited about that
I know Tarantino is a little
controversial but this is supposed to be
one of his most pulp fiction like movies
since the whole thing so I which is
potentially centered on the cultural
backdrop above the Charles Manson
tate-labianca murders
Bruce Lee is in the movie it's also
controversial how is Bruce Lee not I
mean someone's playing Bruce Lee in the
movie yeah why not
it's controversial because it centers
around the Manson murders in people and
some of the family members are saying
yeah you can't make a movie about that
which I don't who knows I mean I don't
know who knows what he's gonna do but
it's hard to ignore I know you know I
guess I don't understand we make movies
about historical murders all the time
we should mention I mean we should
mention it chapter 2 comes out I want to
mention it yeah I'm excited
it was my other and I've got one more
actually it and get out were two of my
favorite movies of 2018 and watch both
like Locke and I have kind of become
horror movie buddies and we went to see
it and get out together and again the
bat the balance of horror with comedy
that was brilliant the way that they I
thought it was really a lot of people
said that they weren't scared by
Pennywise again I don't I don't
understand
it was great check your pulse man but uh
I thought it was great and I and I and
it was as we've already discussed on the
podcast not even comparable to the
original original sucked it's compared
to the new one don't even get me started
on that and let me let me give you a
couple of let me give you a couple of
Tippit's now first of all in the book in
the in the book it written by Stephen
King they kind of go between the
original you know the band of kids I see
1989 when there were kids and then 20 is
it 27 years later in 2016 is when it
well in the book it was there was 26
years or 27 years between the two time
periods and whatever when he wrote it
but anyway it's the modern day 2016 is
when it's supposed to take place but
they're going back and kind of accessing
memories and so you're seeing the kids
from the original movie but then all the
kids grown up played by James McAvoy
well you hold on you just said that yeah
into you kind of minced the two
in the book oh so that's presented as a
flasher they're doing that in the movie
it was just presented as kids and then
at the end there's kind of like okay now
they're gonna get older and so now we
know yeah in this second movie
it's them coming back as adults and then
there's but we know that there's
flashbacks because Nick Hamilton is that
that's the bully yeah so he's a mythical
Nick Hamilton shout out to Nick fan of
the show mythical beast Australian plays
played the bully just a complete gist
horribly awesomely horrible guy in it
he's he's reached out to us and we were
gonna we were gonna actually spend some
time with him when we went to Australia
but he was in Melbourne guess what he
was filming it to it chapter two and he
couldn't be there so we know he's in it
hopefully doesn't get cut
no but Nick's a great guy we hope to
actually meet at some point maybe have
on the show you say he's a great guy he
is because because he likes us yeah yeah
yeah he's got great taste
that usually that usually translate
ain't great character his his his
Twitter messages were very amicable yeah
so that's that's enough for us to
believe he's eclectic in order to play a
character that evil that well I think
you actually have to be very good as a
you know morally as a person anyway the
kids the grown-ups in the movie the
grown-up kids played by James McAvoy
Jessica Chastain Jay Ryan Bill Hader
Bill hader's in it Isaiah Mustafa the
Old Spice guy isn't it I met him in a in
us in a sports attic or some sort of
shop to sell shoes and talk to him talk
to him about shoes I think oh just about
shoes you didn't say you're not on a
horse or anything like that right James
we've met both Old Spice men men Terry
Crews Herrick as well yeah James Ransone
and Andy bean anyway I'm super excited
about it again it's the kind of thing
that
I'll definitely see that it's difficult
to imagine it being as good as the first
wine it's easier than the but it is he
it's not the short stories the second
half of a story yeah right I already
said it man I said it was horrible I
said that the the 1990 version was
horrible now let it's not even watchable
garbage let me tell you speaking of not
garbage okay speaking of amazing news
this year Tyler Perry's Ahmadiyya family
funeral comes out Wow and this is the
last and it will be the tenth Madea
movie I was gonna get you to guess and
then I forgot which I guess the tent
from Adia movie I would have said the
15th no I would have certainly
definitely said double digits Devin I
was surprised so it's the tenth and he
said that it is the last one I don't
know if she dies but I do know I'm not
gonna see it I'm just gonna be very I'm
really looking forward to it coming out
though it's just like he needs to put it
to bed have you ever watched one I
haven't maybe that's the brought you
know what what you know what we need to
do we need to be a measure we need to
catch up sorry can we can get on the
Madea train let's watch nine movies in
one sitting and just wear like bags that
we pee in hold on like literally not get
up the whole hold on I I film the whole
I'm legitimately getting excited about
this so watch out I think that we should
Retton links Madea marathan we should
watch every we should make it into an
event where we watch all nine oh my gosh
what I was correct seriously we cannot
get up no we know I'm not doing you have
to pee into a stadium now the bag no no
I have to put on the external that's not
healthy I don't want to do anything
that's gonna cause me lasting physical
damage one of the things I was gonna
tell you about I was gonna save it from
my personal section but I'll go ahead
say I'm thinking about wearing one to
work in 2019 because I keep having to
get up from meetings to pee and I'm
having to pee more often as I get older
and so I was just like I'm gonna wear
the
freakin thing that I can just pee right
into it I feel like this idea makes it
worse but let's have a constructive
brainstorming moment here and hashtag
ear biscuits let us know I mean I think
this is can be a seminal mythical moment
for 2019 leading up to the midea
premiere which we are going to attend in
person but we will come straight from
having watched all nine like how all
nine back to back to back to back to
back to back to back to back to back
that's got to be at least 18 hours yes
and we're gonna we'll be sleep-deprived
we're gonna be nutty and you apparently
will have not stayed in one place that's
fine for you man and like live your
world and I'm not gonna crap in a bag I
gotta get up for that let's not let's
not leave this let's leave it for now
but let's not leave this idea okay okay
but we're gonna catch up Tyler Perry has
to acknowledge this though I'm not doing
it if he doesn't acknowledge it it's not
that I'm happy that it's over I was just
making a joke at the midea series
expense but it's really that I've never
watched any of them and so why would I
start with the tenth one and we're gonna
saw I've watched bits and pieces of the
ones that have been on television and I
always find them funny you have to go
into a certain mode and sort of say that
this is the type of comedy you know it's
it's it's there's a reason why he's made
ten yeah and once you kind of say this
is not supposed to be some like super
art houses are sophisticated this is
just this is low-hanging fruit humor man
it's really funny okay it's almost
sophisticated in how broad it is you
know
so speaking of ketchup let's move to
television and I'm just gonna throw out
two things here stranger things three
it's coming out excited about that I
never watched all of season two oh well
then that says something about how
excited you are about season three my
family left me in the dust and I never
went back so I got to go back and watch
season two I think before I can watch
season three but maybe not but like oh
that person still here not dead okay
just watch the recap man okay let's
watch the
season recap speaking to catch up I do
have one more okay I've got a TV show
I'm very excited about but go ahead Game
of Thrones they have announced that
probably beginning March April
probably more specific by the time this
comes out season 8 which is the final
season the final six episodes the game
of Thrones are coming out that's that's
pretty huge I mean that's I mean that's
like a cultural phenomenon coming to a
close and I just checked before I came
in here because I could I don't know
where I'm at in the series and I'm a
episode 2 of season 5 so I think I'm in
trouble here because once there's no way
I can catch up before they start to come
out and that's really what you need to
do because at the rate I'm going it'll
be like another year from now and I'll
finally be at the very earliest I'll be
caught up I mean it was it was this time
last year that I started season 1 I went
through five seasons so it took me a
whole year and I'm you're further back
to nail a season three you basically
gave your all you're done I am ever
gonna go back to it I read all the books
and then I that made it a very
satisfying experience for me to watch
what I've watched but my point is once
it's done and it's all in the can I
don't think I'll be motivated to keep
watching but I would love to be able to
catch up and then be a part of the the
cultural conversation I just don't think
I can do it unless it's all I do and I
make use of that pee bag you're talking
there's no way that you can catch up in
time but that doesn't mean you shouldn't
eventually watch it I just don't think
practically I will you said now do it if
you're still going at us at a snail's
pace right now it's never ending but
there's a motivational business there's
real fresh episodes coming out it's a
it's a motivation to keep trying to
catch up do you think this is like this
is this a personality this is being with
me yeah this is a flaw to me this is the
same argument that I got into with my
son about watch
recorded sports events and so m''d say
don't tell me the score and don't watch
it and don't look on the internet
because when we get home we're gonna
watch said game what if it's the Super
Bowl though I mean Super Bowl is a
different thing because I'm not
interested I don't care about the
results of the Super Bowl
I just watch to see role because it's a
cultural phenomena what I'm saying like
it's a date game but what if you did I
think it needs to be the Super Bowl Plus
you cared about the results because
that's really that captures more the
culture of phenomenon of how they're
going to end this whole thing how
they're gonna wrap it up like you're
talking about the inevitability of it
being spoiled for you just by being a
part of conversations in Los Angeles
that's a different thing but I'm talking
about that's not what you said what you
said was is that you're looking for
motivation and knowing that it was still
going give you motivation which is again
back to my argument yeah that said he
didn't want to watch the game because it
had already happened and I was like well
technically what you're seeing on screen
has already happened there's a very
small delay does that mean that he's not
you just because you're not there but
the experience no I think the same it's
not the same because you factor in the
cultural component of even if it's just
talking with one person about it yeah I
would say oh yeah I remember that game
that you watched two weeks ago I watched
it today let's talk about it okay I
don't really want well okay alright so
maybe you got a point because if I saved
let's say I saved maybe like a state
Carolina game that takes dick what if I
decided to skip watching like a state
Carolina game which is a game that I
care about the outcome of and I skip the
one in 2019 at one of their games in
2019 and I say where for like 2023 at
that point I'm not invested because it
has no impact on the current Proceedings
of the season and the standings and
there's different players so I watch
madam and maybe maybe that makes sense I
watch Mad Men totally late and it was
what is the same shows it was amazing
but I missed out on an added component
that I think the social component yeah
and but I did get through mad man but
didn't you want to slide into the story
yes so that's different and then
for but I'll never watch The Sopranos so
I don't know it kind of goes both ways
this is like you might I won't know I'm
saying I will never watch this I tried I
heard it I was like no I have no one to
talk to about this to help keep me going
well what if I started watching it
Sopranos buddies is that our thing you
and me The Sopranos yeah I like when
we're in a Retirement Center you know
I'm saying I'm sorry like when we've got
a lot of time but you're gonna be
looking for stuff to bench man it's
gonna feel like watching a silent film
at that point if I live as long as I
hope to live TV that I am incredibly
excited about which we have a fun little
story about this one so you may remember
I've talked about it before I talked
about it on the internet 2014 movie
called what we do in the shadows which
was it had Jemaine Clement from Flight
of the Conchords and Tycho ytt New
Zealand based director who directed Thor
that's what he's known for but he did a
lot of amazing work before that
continues to do incredible stuff they
were actually both that they created and
were to start in this movie which was a
vampire mockumentary which was just
I tweet about how it was but when I
watched it was my favorite movie with
2014 so far it may be my favorite movie
of 2014 and again it was one of those
things it's just like first of all these
guys are funny I find everything that
that sort of loose group of New
Zealanders do Kiwis those Kiwis are
incredibly funny like I love ya there
since it's a specific dryness um and
they're just like friendly dryness like
I just and they just I just take a
British dryness but then you make it
happy it's one of those things where
every once in a while you like see guys
you're doing something and you kind of
know that they're they work together in
their friends and I'm just like man I
would like to be friends with those guys
the movie had a very labor of love
quality and I know that like all the
sketches and things they one of them did
themselves and was just like is very
unnecessary but very labor of love ish
what and now it was just cool he was
hilarious
and it was not something when you
something it was a mockumentary it's
like you would have thought that well
you can't do those anymore like they're
done mockumentary czar done old played
out no it wasn't it was incredibly funny
and they are bringing that show that
movie back to life as a television show
on FX
that premieres spring of this year 2019
now there's a few things that are
different first of all Jemaine and tyka
are involved in fact the way we found
out about this before it was public was
we actually met a PR rep from FX who I
was like we were talking about FX and
how much we loved FX and all the shows
on there and she said well have you
heard of what we do in the shadows I was
like yes and she's like it's gonna be a
television show and the inside
information that I got at the time which
was probably public at this point is
that Tyco was directing and Jemaine was
show running so basically they are very
involved creatively but a few things to
note it's not the same group of people
it's a different time different place to
take there's no shadows it's still very
shadowy are there vampires
I believe so takes place in New York
specifically Staten Island and other
boroughs okay why do you need other
boroughs if you got Staten Island all
new lead lead characters so nobody from
the movie not just actors but I think
it's actually different characters is
what's my understanding of that so in
Paul Sims who's the you know the guy who
collaborated with Flight of the
Conchords for their television show and
also as a producer on Atlanta is
producing it oh so we're talking about a
dude who just the people involved are so
talented that it just feels like it has
to work and it has to be great and the
Doug Jones who played the infinium man
in the shape of water he's one of the
actors in it oh I don't know if he plays
an amphibian but I think he's got I
think he's got range I think he can do
not and fibia to work anyway sometime in
2019 that is the television that I am
extremely excited about yeah oh and I'll
be I'll be kids
up I'll just be over here doing my
ketchup
shall we shift to music
we shall shift there's not a place
there's not a repository on the internet
that has a reliable these are albums
that are coming out and there's like a
wiki entry but it it's very it's too
comprehensive to be useful well the
first thing is it's not related to a new
album coming out because that's the
thing that I looked at and I didn't you
know I didn't have I didn't find
anything specifically I was too excited
about honestly okay
I got something that's notable but okay
but um
Rolling Stones they're doing a tour how
do I know about this and my huge Rolling
Stone fan no I really like the album
tattoo you specifically the b-side I'm
just waiting on a friend and laid and
the reason you like that it's because I
happen to order it on being ug way back
in the day that's I don't know why
that's the Rolling Stone album you got
I'm glad it was Rolling Stones I've
listened to a love that was we loved it
to me that was like their sweet spot of
that like funk rock thing that they were
doing that I don't know what the B PM's
were but they're a little bit slower
yeah well it has just one there was one
like the one big hit on it I can't
remember which one it was but it's it
wasn't a satisfaction but it was
basically like the one that if you don't
know the wrongest stones you still know
it but then it I think it's the first
song on the album which I again I
usually listen to the B side as well
but I'm going to they're their show at
the Rose Bowl because Britain texted me
and he was like Rolling Stones coming to
the Rose Bowl let's do it I'm like I
don't want to be a fart oh no hugging so
I just sat on the text a little bit and
I'm like well when is it yeah start me
up I start me up with well you know what
this is and I'm like yes let's do it now
I'm excited about it well let me give
you a couple of pointers having been it
to a show at the Rose Bowl in a very
similar situation when Mike Edwards came
into town he's a big u2 fan and I'm not
not a u2 fan but I am I understand and
appreciate what they've done
there's some songs that I like but I'm
not like yeah you know do I need to
listen to the Rolling Stones and like
really become like a superfan well what
I was gonna say what I was gonna say is
you need to you need to talk to some
people and get and try to get down in
the little area of next to the stage
which what do you mean you pulled you
know you pull some strings you talk to
some people or ticket burners or oh hey
I'm internet famous and get like a
backstage pass well you cannot get a
backstage pass not to the rollers Mick
Jagger's I'm gonna let you within a
hundred feet but I'm saying you can get
into the into the lumière Oreo and be I
was the u2 concert I was like right next
to the little keystone thing that bono
comes out on did you do that instead of
getting a seat
I already had tickets I already have
tickets and then I was like ah you know
what I should do actually figure out if
I could get something some special when
first of all maybe I shouldn't I got no
no first of all when you call who you
need to call in order to try to get the
thing we're talking you got to make them
think that they're not actually doing
anything for you and it usually works
and you could get great seats so instead
you're be standing you can get Mick
Jagger sweat on your face never wash
again now but here's what but here's the
other thing but I'll be doing stunad
Drive do not drive okay all right do not
drive what is this bull this is getting
titillating in it because don't drive to
the road you know how long ice Mike and
I stayed in my car after the u2 concert
waiting to leave an hour 90 minutes
before we moved oh wow so unless you've
got a book on tape or you just want to
go deep in a conversation with Britain
you need to fight and get a helicopter
yeah so come on I got a helicopter drop
it right into it off so let me get this
straight when the show was over you went
back to the car and then you start it up
but then you couldn't get no motion
music I'm not excited about but I know a
lot of people are
there are four albums coming out from
from bands that some of you may like
Tesla first of all Tesla is a band not
just a brand Megadeth Skid Row and
Whitesnake hair metal bands all just
decided 2019 is the year of hair metal
its back it's something about add as
ever something about their age and their
their fan their sweet spot of their fans
age it's gotta have something to do with
that it doesn't have anything to do with
me I will say that yeah I will not be
partaking unless Britain drags me to
some of that too
I don't know I don't think he's into
that it's a it's funny because this is
not I mean first of all there are people
who would be like you know you can't put
Megadeth and Whitesnake in the same
category I understand that there's
probably that's probably faux pas for
metalheads yeah but I just don't know
anything about it and I don't have any
desire to but I appreciate it again and
I here's something you're gonna
appreciate if they came to the Rose Bowl
knocked on her door
[Music]
but here's one new album coming out from
hootie and the blowfish
hoody teamed back up with the Blowfish
you know he had a his country now
he was country he still is country I
know his name is Darius Rucker but he's
always gonna be Hootie to me and he
never was to anybody officially but he's
teaming back up with his people did you
know with the Blowfish did you know that
Darius Rucker did a song with Lionel do
you know that Lionel did an album called
Tuskegee yeah that was a collaboration
with a bunch of country artists and by
2016
I don't listen to Lionel now I listen to
the Lionel that was just a sweet sweet
spot la well he doesn't he does do it
with Rascal Flatts do on that which was
it wasn't one of my favorite songs but
in its you know when when people like
Lionel
do things in the present day sometimes
it has especially when they're
collaborating with country stars the
polish is it's over polished yeah to the
point that you feel like it loses a
little bit of soul yeah there are some
there are some really really good songs
in fact I think you're sure I think
you're not who did she go in your dad
nests know what Izzy there's nothing to
legit about this hold on there you
haven't listened to it you can't judge
it man I'm saying it's great I'm sure
it's great what does he do a Darius
Rucker what song does he do I know is
your tongue what you're telling me is
you're going to the Hootie and the
Blowfish you know you're waiting in the
line for their album Darius and that's
kind of it all goes yeah they did stuck
on you together in the harmonies are
great I'm sure it's great it's you need
to listen just not relevant why do I
care about that okay that's good I care
about what sticks to my soul man and
Lionel and Darius Rucker sing and
styling I don't I don't I don't like
artists covering their own material
decades later period period if it's if
you know easy like Sunday morning leave
it on that Sunday morning don't give me
the updated version and it's for a Merle
you know any it just doesn't work it's
it's there's a sadness to it even if it
sounds great I'm like I'm relieved that
Lionel's duet with Hootie sounds good
but and I think he still got it but I
don't want him to cover his his old
songs 20 years later and here's the
thing that I hated that with streaming
music they can they can still sneak it
in there but they I don't I think the
industry doesn't allow for it as much
anymore
I hope I'm right about this because it
when the reborn intact
well we'll release an album of their
greatest hits but it they're they've
covered their own songs so that they
can't is something about how they can
make money off of it but it's the it's
the artist covering their own song
decades later yes you do they're like
surrounded by waste that's different
hate that I hate that as well and then
but a different let me listen to like oh
you you like Lionel let me listen to
some line on there going on Spotify in
there listening like 2016 Lionel
with hoody do you know who like they get
a totally wrong impression of how
amazing it is but you know who Lionel
sings easy with on the album Alabama
Willie Nelson man ok ok you this is
Willie Nelson
hold on cept that's different though oh
my gosh I just realized I had a dream
about Willie Nelson last night you and
me we were sitting we were sitting
somewhere like on bleachers I was
sitting here you were on my left and
then I was looking at you and then I
leaned forward and who was there he's a
like son and mom Willie Willie Nelson
Willie Nelson was like just on the other
side of him he was that I could have
reached out and touched him if you
weren't in the way and you know what he
likes you know what I you know what I
did I leaned over into your ear and I
said he's a good-looking man still got
it that's not what he's known for
he he's really held up well those are
the three things I said yeah old early
that's why early he looked old at 30
that's the old early I'm not saying he's
attractive I'm saying he's a looks good
and he sounds good because he also
sounded old early just like Kris
Kristofferson if you sound old early you
throw down great forever it was
thrilling okay be that close to you mr.
Nelson in a dream and the reason why I
have the dream is because we have a
urinal on the other side and when you're
peeing in that urinal right above the
urinal there is a that's my picture a
portrait of Willie Nelson staring you
right in the face my wife got me that
and and I didn't have a place to put it
up inside your house my house because it
was she was thinking that we would put
it up in the office and then she just
put it up over one of the urinals I mean
nothing I don't mind Willie watching me
pee nothing makes me relax my prostate
like staring deep into the eye holes of
Willie Nelson Willie can watch me when
my Willie any time Willie let's move on
to technology why don't we let's do it
Tesla 5g is coming what does this mean
I've heard about this I'm like you know
I'm not talking about when you're on
your Wi-Fi and it's like there's a 5g
option right that's bullcrap it's like
you got two different bands on your
router and no one ever tells you it's
what you're supposed to connect to 5g is
the fifth generation making me angry I
think you you just really you've you've
peed in my feet in your grits in my
cornflakes somebody your cornflake has
gotten in my bowl 5g is the fifth
generation of mobile of wireless
technology okay so obviously you
remember 3G and then it turned into 4G /
LTE and you remember the jump
you probably don't but if you don't
remember the jump from 3G to 4G it
basically went from forget about ever
watching a video on your phone to oh I'm
watching a video Alma yeah okay and you
you you forget that and sometimes if
you're if you're out and about and you
which is definitely the case in Los
Angeles because of the mountains and the
weirdness
you can suddenly find yourself in a 3G
spot and it's almost like you don't even
have a phone anymore I mean you might be
able to text you can have a conversation
but you're not gonna go you're not gonna
use any - you only have what used to be
a film right the step from 4G to 5g will
be as significant or more significant so
what am I going to experience because if
it's not video streaming video well
first of all you're gonna the the
internet connection will be 10 times as
fast okay 10 times as fast as LTE
latency will be reduced to a millisecond
it will be it will be unnoticeable so
basically this means a whole lot that is
I'm not an expert on this but I can read
articles and tell you what they say
essentially for the it's gonna do a
number of things this is sort of the
beginning of the end of there being a
point of reference for things taking
time over the Internet
okay so we still live in a world in
which we wait for things we see
something spinning on netflix to load
etc and this kind of thing but
this is the beginning of their being
wirelessly in the air broadcast
everywhere accessible to any device that
can tap into it not waiting for anything
now of course it's technology it's gonna
screw up but you're gonna get frustrated
with it just like any technology all
right this is people will start making
things like now we're gonna start
streaming 3d environments but you're
gonna you're gonna feel like you can't
live without it and then you're gonna be
frustrated with it loading well loading
isn't I don't mean like a hologram so I
don't know how much actually so
Holograms not so much but they are so
augmented reality virtual reality the
fact that we're gonna get down to
wireless late in latency being so small
you're not gonna have to have a console
to experience because basically you have
to have a real-world device you've got
to have like a phone that you're putting
into a device you've got to have glut
Google glasses you've got to have
something that's on your person that
isn't tethered to something in order to
really be immersed into the world of
like to bring augmented reality to our
world we have to have something that is
out and about and is everywhere is I can
take it to the grocery store it's gonna
change the way I interact with
everything 5g is the beginning of that
happening it's like the things are kind
of settling and but there it will be
that significant also any technology
that were like cart like self-driving
cars like autonomous cars being able to
communicate with each other and
communicate with the Internet in a way
that's fast enough for them to like be
reliably kind of dependent upon this
like inter connected network it's that
that's going to happen with 5g and it's
being rolled out it actually there's a
it's being rolled out in a number of
cities it depends on who your carrier is
but basically you're also going to not
have to have a cable coming into your
house you're gonna have you're gonna
have a wireless modem that captures the
5g and then that modem is your local
Wi-Fi is going to be broadcast around
your house into your television and all
this stuff you're not gonna be drilling
holes into your house the Cable guy's
not going to come out and have to go and
say well a true limb fell on your cable
you're screwed that's not gonna happen
because it's all gonna be wireless 5g
man
welcome to the frickin future the thing
I found was elected cities Elan musk is
gonna be sending people into space and
to the international space station on
his Space Shuttle the dragon Boeing's
working on one - they're supposed to
have out and there's there's been some
unmanned well right now our our
astronauts have to hitch a ride on the
Russian shuttles to get to the
International Space Station so nASA has
contracted with SpaceX and Boeing to to
have our own shuttle system well how
hard that's gonna be for us to work out
doing our Madea reunion
medea marathon at the International
Space Station on the way well that's
gonna be much easier this year Elon if
you're watching I know you're a fan if
you would like us to have our Madea
Marathon on the international space
station if you feel like you can pull
the right strings we're talking a pee in
a bag I'll pee out in the open
your pee just turns into a yellow ball
in space right and then you can cut it
like an apple or the net so whatever
whatever you want whatever it takes
Tyler Perry doesn't even have to be
there if we can do it all in the
International Space Station
Elon Musk's cars will have will be
playing the new Tesla album only they've
he they've worked out a deal no they
will they should work out a deal first
of all he tweeted this around Halloween
of last year but that a Tesla will be
able to drive around a parking lot and
find an empty spot read signs to confirm
it's valid and park that's helpful and
illegal you know that I mean there's two
men on a state level they have to create
laws in terms of like cell drawers and
stuff like that
users you know so it's like if the the
valet so it's just one more thing that's
like tempting me as I'm now maybe I need
to get one of those Tesla's maybe you do
man you ought to get one splurge a
little bit lards I just can't bring
myself to something like that I don't
know maybe um Jazzercise is going to be
celebrating 50 years oh now we come to
it the good stuff
I don't even exactly know what
Jazzercise is because I'm picturing like
Jane Fonda leotards my mom used to take
me to the church fellowship hall and I
have to sit in the corner and like color
while she was jumping around and would
like leg warmers off she was probably
doing Jazzercise but she was doing the
like Church version when Amy Grant was
involved it's a system it's a franchise
well I don't know if they do it at
churches maybe they do but it is a
franchise they haven't 50 years oh well
let me tell you a little bit about this
because when I found this is Jane Fonda
decided Jane Fonda part of Jazzercise I
do not believe so it was it was started
by someone the name like Shepherd Miss
it or something like that
okay so we've started in 1969 hence 50
years ago this is crazy by 1984
Jazzercise was declared the second
fastest growing franchise behind
Domino's Pizza did you know this was
happening you've got a license it to do
it today the company boasts eighty three
hundred franchises in 32 countries and
earns roughly one hundred million
dollars per year there's 200,000
customers dancing and sweating to
Jazzercise choreography each year
millions of lives this is like the press
release this is them from mark what what
they wrote yeah well it's no it's all
true you think Jazzercise is gonna you
lie to you
millions of lives 50-year history
Jazzercise now this is where Meijer this
is where my thighs started perking up
geser size will celebrate the golden
anniversary body part with a your thighs
working jazz they don't perk up though
mine do you wanna see my thighs perk up
there are things that can get perky but
the thighs aren't two of them Jazzercise
will celebrate the golden anniversary
with a two-day international convention
and party June 28th through 29th 2019 at
the San Diego Convention Center in San
Diego over two thousand people will
attend the event that will be filled
with dance fitness classes live
entertainment international guest
performers surprise announcements and
big reveals about the brand's future
we got to play Jazzercise yes performer
we gotta play Jazzercise what if we
could play Jazzercise do a concert at
Jazzercise 50th golden anniversary and
do the Madea Marathon there this is
gonna be a big year for us clear your
calendar link my thighs are gonna be so
perky on June 28th and 29th I mean we
line up and see him jump the thing that
we are doing is creating more tour dates
for just added one right in our music
and concert extravaganza
so mm-hmm I mean I don't mean to turn
this into an announcement but yeah we're
gonna be at Jazzercise San Diego well
well we're gonna be in London next month
February 4 in association with VidCon we
have our own concert rhett and Link
live.com check on tickets for that in
April we're going to be in Nashville st.
Louis and Columbus and the DC Maryland
area so that's four shows the national
show is gonna be at the Ryman which was
it pretty exciting the birthplace of the
Grand Ole Opry which of course then
moved but Mike that's the original stage
man I'm so excited
reading live.com if you want to come see
us I mean I bringing it I'm like I'm not
just trying to make this a plug I think
that that's a big thing I'm looking
forward to in 2019 that we haven't been
able to talk about is like the specific
tour dates and again we're still we're
looking to do some more write music for
it new music coming yeah what about
personally let's get to some things that
we're looking forward to personally
I'm doing something I've never done
before in 2019 this is an ambitious man
when you first told me about this I was
like whoa really
when I looked at the price tag I was
like I do you gonna do this I am doing
it I booked it today as a matter of fact
so I am taking the McLaughlin's or
should I say the McLaughlin's to
Scotland I have been and how many how
many McLaughlin's are we talking about
twelve how big is the clan twelve twelve
people okay so here's the deal I've been
thinking about doing this for a while I
always thought that it would be an
unforgettable experience to take all the
people that I know in love with the last
name McLaughlin to the motherland and
but you did you tell any of them that no
I told him when I was done knew I was
gonna do it it was in your mind but you
didn't tell them one day I hope to take
you to Scotland no I've never said that
I've only thought it and I first of all
they're very excited how did you tell
him was it this is like a this is like a
gender-reveal or something
like you got to make a big deal out of
it I just thought that I shouldn't do
that I didn't want to make a big I
wanted to make that look at what I'm
doing I wanted to make the big to do
just the going okay that's admirable so
I just told him when I was home I told
him when I was home for the State Fair
you know in October and they were all
very excited cuz I was like you don't
know if they're gonna be able to do it
you don't know what their schedules are
it has to work out with when we're gonna
be able to be getting away so anyway so
this is this is who I'm taking I'm
taking course my family that's four
people
I'm taking my parents that makes six
and I'm taking my brother and his wife
and their four children so there's 12 of
us all together and we are putting
together the itinerary right now now I
have never traced my family back
specifically but you just I've done a
little bit of like the ancestry
and it kind of gets a little murky like
around the 1700s we don't go back very
far we it seems that like both sides of
the family come from like poor farmers
that didn't really have any way like did
you know you had you had to be of a
certain class in order to kind of get
traced back I'm sure I could do it if I
did a little bit more research but
anyway because our last name is
McLaughlin McLaughlin is probably what I
should start saying we do know that
McLaughlin is a derivative of mcLaughlin
basically they it becomes like MCL ACH
LAN and then we know that McLaughlin is
a derivative of Lachlan and so the lock
because the you know they would add the
MCS because there was some sort of
family dispute or whatever anyway the
Lachlan clan still exists still has a
chief a chief yeah chieftain whatever
they call him and there's the old ruin
basically you've got the old Lachlan
castle which is on a lock in Scotland
and then you've got the new Lachlan
castle which is where the chief still
lives so does everybody pay dues I mean
wait there's it's a castle it's not a
homeowner's association well how does it
family so is it a castle it's like a
hotel now there's like a hotel or a
restaurant there I think but III think
that I think a lot of the the heritage
goes way back you know and in in in the
British Isles and so I think that there
are plenty of families that still have
some sort of structure intact and you
know you've got your I don't even I'm so
I'm so bad I don't know that you've got
like your family shield or whatever you
call it which I'm I'm gonna know all
these trying to figure it out you're not
going next month you're going later and
and I I'm planning the ins and outs of
what we're gonna do but we hope to like
meet the chief and I'm gonna submit you
know my application to take his place
when he passes so I can live in a castle
in Scotland and I don't think the
central air and heating is great in
those things oh okay well you might want
to check you get a tour first before you
bend the knee we could do the Medea
we could do the midea marathon there I
can bring you know what kind of internet
don't know if they got 5g but anyway
that's a hang back
super ambition you have a family thing
it's it's a little interesting there's
holes in castles and you you squat down
and you dump in them and then it goes
down into the moat
I just just runs down the side of the
castle that's how those things work I
think they have plumbing I the reason I
decided to do it is because my oldest
nephew is turning 18 this year and you
know he's gonna be off at college and
it's like this is like the last time
when we're all kind of all living as
intact families to go off and take over
the Scottish countryside yeah I mean if
he if he you know partners up starts
having kids that's that's more people
you got to take you I'm not doing that
you gotta get it over with before they
start procreating it so anyway the next
generation of McLaughlin I'm looking
forward to that you want to make some
memories man that's cool I commend you
on that I can you know it with you
taking a vacation like that means I got
to figure something out
yeah you do yeah I think I just might
have I don't know I'm thinking maybe
Scotland I don't know I don't know what
I'm gonna do I do know that we're
planning a trip for Lille 16th birthday
we we said we had some friends who did
this like one every year they have
multiple kids and they're like alright
but kid gets to decide what they're
doing they have like a special trip and
I'm like for Lille 16th we're gonna give
her one of those where it's like just us
just her her mom and me are gonna go and
do a special 16th you know something
that she'll remember and make it special
anywhere she wants to go which is kind
of what's that gonna be she wants to go
to London I think because of all this
Doctor Who and Harry Potter and all this
stuff she's been into she having never
been there she's always wanted to go and
experience the life of London of course
so I mean I I think I may end up well
we're doing a show there it's separate
from that so I'm gonna get I'm gonna get
my share of London this year
well you know and I'm gonna love it
after the malavya London after the
McLaughlin's leave Scotland the the rest
of the McLaughlin's besides my little
clan we're sticking around and we're
driving across the United Kingdom
countryside in towards London and then
ending in London okay you're gonna get
some London so I'm gonna have to get
London tips yeah we both need some
London tips y'all hashtag ear biscuits
lots to look forward to this year
there's lots of other stuff we got in
the works there's a big project we've
been working on for a while that will I
think in in a few weeks will start
teasing that out but we can't yet talk
about it but just be on the lookout for
that what are you looking forward to
this year a good start to the yeah I'm
feeling great about 2019 if you haven't
made your resolutions it's not too late
or you don't make resolutions just just
find things that other people are doing
that you can look forward to yeah that's
what Mike did like we did today like you
can be a movie can be a little blip on
your calendar make your resolution I'm
going to watch a movie that I want to
watch and then you'll feel good about
yourself it's the little things
that's the barlow and jump right over it
alright also I wanted to say the video
version of this is now living on another
channel as well as all video versions
well all ear biscuits past present and
future are gonna be at youtube.com slash
ear biscuits so all those old interviews
from previous seasons all that stuff if
you want the Youtube version in the
video version everything moving forward
that's where you need to subscribe and
if you can't spell biscuit like I can't
it's bis see you I T you can remember
that because it's like this quit C uit
it's like a sentence this quit it's just
like the way I remember how to spell
school it's s CH oo L because school's
not cool that's how I used to remember
that not cool yeah
school's not cool it doesn't have the
word cool in it all right the word houl
in it we cool tool broken the seal on a
new year man whoa yep there we go
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]